[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous bon soir
grégory on sent mathilde ravi d'être
avec vous c'est une première pour nous
une co présentation des missions et ils
feraient bien effective quel est le
programme de ce set 8 on explique le 7-8
c'est une heure d'information
d'actualité des interviews également des
découvertes on aura l'occasion d'aller
notamment faire du manège et un
programme chargé lors d'un programme
très chargé rempli de plein de
thématiques voici les titres c'est
historique jamais une femme n'avait
occupé ce poste auparavant la députée de
la 5e circonscription des yvelines il ya
est lebron pie v a été élue présidente
de l'assemblée nationale
nous étions sur place pour recueillir sa
première réaction le tour de france
s'élancera ce vendredi 1er juillet de
copenhague au danemark
la dernière étape passera par les
yvelines l'un des incontournables de cet
événement la fameuse caravane du tour
nous sommes allés à la rencontre d'une
animatrice elle nous livre les coulisses
et son ressenti sur la grande boucle
enfin la fête des loges revient au coeur
de la forêt de saint germain les
jusqu'au 15 août avec plus de 200
attractions les petits et les grands
trouveront de quoi se divertir deux
journalistes de la rédaction se sont
défiés sur certains manèges le gagnant
sera connu en fin d'émission mais on
aura également des invités au cours de
cette émission on aura l'occasion de
parler emploi pouvoir d'achat culture
également programme très chargé mais
doute tout de suite vous en avez
l'habitude dans cette nouvelle formule
du 7-8 c'est les infos à ne pas manquer
dans les yvelines ce avec justin brasier
bonsoir justine et on commence du coup
avec cette information donc parler
mathilde c'est la députée des yvelines
yale brawn peavey qui a été élue
présidente de l'assemblée nationale
c'est la première femme à occuper cette
fonction une information mise en avant
dans son discours elle je cite il aura
fallu attendre près d'un demi siècle que
pour que les premières femmes rentrent
dans cet hémicycle le vote a lieu hier
mardi 28 juin ayez le brevet a été élu à
l'issue du second tour avec 242 voix
elle succède ainsi à richard ferrand
vôtre informations c'est le centre des
restos du coeur de magnanville qui vient
d'être inauguré si le centre avait
ouvert ses portes en février 2022 il a
été inauguré comme vous venez de le dire
ce mercredi 29 juin et bilan depuis son
ouverture 730 personnes sont accueillis
régulièrement pour une moyenne de 3000
repas distribués chaque semaine à noter
le centre fermera ses portes pour l'été
mais il rouvrira le 6 septembre et au
tri nul hier une opération celle du
lycée franco allemand de buc will a
ouvert en 1975 le lycée s'est refait une
beauté l'établissement symbolique de
l'amitié franco allemande s'est agrandie
avec à douze mille cinq cents mètres
carrés d'espacé neuf courts et
structurée est le lycée pour accueillir
à présent très 2300 élèves une
rénovation qui a nécessité deux ans de
travaux et un budget de 56 millions
d'euros mais du côté de fois si les
habitants connaîtront leur nouveau maire
ce week end oui suite à l'élection de
karl olive en tant que député de la 12e
circonscription aux élections
législatives et face à la règle de non
cumul des mandats ce dernier doit donc
céder sa place le conseil municipal de
poissy se réunira dimanche à l'hôtel de
ville pour élire le nouveau maire et ses
sons actuels première adjointe sandrine
dos santos qui devrait lui succéder et
puis alors justin un cimetière animalier
pourrait voir le jour dans le
département c'est en tout cas à la
volonté du maire de carrières sous
poissy eddie aït une information
rapportée par nos confrères du parisien
il s'agirait du seul cimetière animalier
fonctionnel dont les yvelines et le
troisième d'île de france une
consultation citoyenne devrait être
lancé à la fin de l'année merci justin
alors vous l'avez évoqué c'est une
information importante la député de la
5e circonscription des yvelines yaël
boon qui v a été élu hier soir à
l'assemblée nationale présidente et nous
y étions nicolas à l'assemblée hier soir
bonsoir motif
effectivement nous y étions ensemble ils
étaient à peu près 20 heures quand nous
avons pu recueillir sa première réaction
juste après la passation de pouvoir avec
richard ferrand l'ancien président de
l'assemblée nationale
elle a souligné qu'elle était très
attaché aux médias locaux et du coup et
nous a consacré sa première réaction
regarder avec nous la nouvelle
présidente de l'assemblée nationale il
ya et lebron pie v bonsoir ben ça alors
vous venez d'être élu nouvelle
présidente de l'assemblée nationale avec
242 voix au second tour votre réaction
et qu'est ce que ça représente pour vous
c'est beaucoup d'émotion et un grand
honneur que m'ont fait aujourd'hui les
parlementaires en m'élisant président de
l'assemblée nationale j'ai le sentiment
des sentiments mêlés un sentiment de
joie forcément parce que c'est un grand
moment pour une élue d'être élu par ses
pairs pour exercer des responsabilités
c'est un moment important dans notre
histoire puisque je suis la première
femme de l'histoire de la république à
être élue présidente de l'assemblée
nationale et puis c'est un moment
important parce que notre assemblée n'a
jamais été aussi diverses il va falloir
faire en sorte que tout le monde se
parle que tout le monde puisse exercer
son mandat pleinement et donc il y à un
immense défi qui est posé aujourd'hui
alors justement première femme à occuper
cette fonction et parler de votre maman
vous avez parlé aussi de catherine tasca
une autre yvelinoise qui a été la
première présidente de la commission des
lois une fonction que vous avez occupé
aussi c'est important de rendre hommage
à ces femmes là c'est important parce
que
on est toujours le produit d'une
histoire on n'est pas des électrons
libres des éléments isolés donc on
s'inscrit dans un combat pour l'égalité
donc là c'est beaucoup de femmes et
c'est catherine tasca parce que elle a
porté les lois sur la parité qui font
qu'aujourd'hui les femmes sont entrés
pleinement dans les conseils municipaux
dans les conseils départementaux dans
les régions et donc c'est un acte
fondateur pour nous les femmes
politiques et puis ma mère parce que
c'est toujours important de savoir d'où
l'on vient de sa famille et nos parents
nous donne des leçons de vie et ma mère
m'a effectivement appris à ne jamais
résignés et a toujours emprunter le
chemin qui était le mien est pas celui
que les autres choisissait pour moi et
je pense que ça c'est un message
important que l'on peut adresser aux
français alors vous avez parlé de du
d'assemblée divisée qu'elle présidente
vous allez être du coup une présidente
qui permet à chacun d'exister dans cet
hémicycle et de remplir la mission que
le yahoo elle lui a confié les français
donc une une présidente qui laisse faire
le débat et qui fait en sorte que le
débat soit respectueux et permettent
d'avancer vers du conte premier des
consensus parce que c'est ce que les
français attendent de nous j'ai
l'impression que les français sont
contents de l'assemblée nationale qui
l'ont élu à nous de montrer digne
maintenant de leur vote deux dernières
questions d'abord revenir sur cette
cérémonie du tromperie au scope vous
avez été désigné député de l'année par
ce magazine yves thréard avait dit vous
êtes pugnacais je reviens là dessus
cette pugnacité vous l'avez toujours et
on l'a vu aujourd'hui en fait mais oui
en fait c'est vous savez c'est ce qui ce
qui me caractérise mais parce que c'est
c'est important de en fait rien n'a rien
et à qui personne ne vous donne
les choses dans la vie il faut aller les
chercher il faut étudier il faut se
construire il faut aussi construire avec
les autres et c'est ce qui je crois
aussi a été saluée aujourd'hui
l'esprit de consensus dont j'ai toujours
fait preuve mais ça ne ça ne tombe pas
du ciel un dernier mot les yvelines au
coeur du pouvoir législatif une
présidente yvelinoise de l'assemblée
nationale est un président du sénat qui
était vinoy gérard larcher on dit
souvent que les yvelines c'est la plus
petite france parce qu'il y à tous dans
les yvelines et donc voilà c'est
maintenant le coeur des institutions qui
représentait dans les yvelines mais vous
savez une fois qu'on est président et du
sénat et de l'assemblée nationale on est
vraiment on doit être présent sur tous
les territoires merci à lebron tibet
dont la nouvelle présidente de
l'assemblée nationale première femme à
occuper ce poste merci merci à vous et
il ya une bonne cuvée nicolas qui a été
aussi quelques semaines ministre d outre
mer elle nous avait d'ailleurs accordé
sa première réaction juste après sa
nomination à les déranger déjà elle est
dorénavant pardon du coup président de
l'assemblée nationale et c'est une
preuve nicolas que les yvelines sont en
quelque sorte le berceau de la vie
politique française oui je veux
démontrer on va voir mais d'abord
concernant le pouvoir législatif et bien
je les dis on lundi dans ce sujet
d'abord la présidente de l'assemblée
nationale de brut pib dit yvelinoise et
puis de l'autre côté le président du
sénat gérard larcher donc dirige la
seconde chambre qui composent le
parlement en complément à noter aussi
c'est la fonction occupée par aurore
bergé a été élue présidente du groupe
parlementaire renaissance à l'assemblée
nationale et donc du coup pouvoir
législatif les yvelines au coeur du
pouvoir législatif dont on a fait réagir
les députés à ce propos regardez c'est
vrai que pour l'instant les yvelines
s'en sortait bien haut niveau
électorale dans les enceintes des
institutions donc je sais pas s'il ya eu
des précédents mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que voilà on a aussi je pense su
démontrer que on avait des élus engagés
de qualité près aussi à se battre pour
le fonctionnement d'institutions donc
très bonne nouvelle pour nous quoi mais
à écouter ça me laisse espérer un
certain nombre de succès prometteur ce
qui me concerne l'avenir
les yvelines à la tête du pouvoir
législatif et passa fier la cherté de
certains illinois et c'est le cas
notamment du président du conseil
départemental des yvelines pierre bédier
je cite son tweet mes félicitations
républicaines à yaël boon qui vais pour
son élection à la présidence de
l'assemblée nationale avec gérard
larcher à la présidence du sénat de
zibeline on a dirigé les deux chambres
de notre parlement c'est unique dans
l'histoire quel honneur pour les
yvelines et nicolas le pouvoir exécutif
a aussi été représentée par des
yvelinois les yvelinoises eh bien oui
alors vous inquiétez pas y'a pas de
président de la république qui ont été
les noix quoique on peut trouver
quelques liens notamment georges
pompidou qui est enterré arts sont vides
parce que il avait sa résidence
secondaire dans les yvelines mais c'est
plutôt que dans le gouvernement de ça se
passe et c'est le cas notamment de nadia
s'est dernièrement le cas elle était
ministre délégué en charge de la vie
nous avons eu aussi benoît hamon
ministre de l'économie sociale et
solidaire ministre de l'éducation
nationale durant le mandat de françois
hollande sous le quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy valérie pécresse a été ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur et du budget
christine boutin devient ministre du
logement en 2007 revenons aussi en 2004
avec le gouvernement de jean pierre
raffarin gérard larcher a été nice du
travail enfin retour en 1988 michel
rocard qui devient premier ministre de
françois mitterrand il était dans la
commune de conflans sainte honorine et
puis un petit clin d'oeil quand même un
personnage historique de la gauche
française en 1936 léon blum devient chef
du gouvernement du sous le front
populaire en fait et puis bale et ou
blum en fait à sa maison à jouy en josas
dans les yvelines encore une fois les
yeux si nicolas et vous avez terminé par
sa des lieux historiques ou la politique
résonnent encore entre les murs ouais
effectivement d'un gorille direction
bazoches sur guyonne alors pourquoi
bazoches sur guyonne c
le lieu de la maison jean monnet et la
lexus lfa d'atr de l'union européenne
voilà syrienne située le plus possible
maurice est bien grégory c'est moi qui
avais parlé de la gravure au ps
spécialiste des politiques jean monnet
on ne présente plus père fondateur
l'union européenne et c'est dans ce lieu
à la maison jean monnet à bazoches sur
guyonne qu'il a développé sa vision de
la communauté européenne et notamment la
déclaration robert schuman a été rédigé
par jean monnet dans cette demeure c'est
le point de départ de l'union européenne
je vous propose une deuxième de finale
est ce que vous saviez que la
constitution de la vème république a été
rédigée dans les yvelines
mais est ce que ce serait pas versailles
du coup non non non je pensais salle du
jeu de paume et non c'est pas là non
c'est pas sa direction epône juste à
côté de mantes la jolie et bien michel
debré et quatre ministres d'état ont
travaillé sur la constitution de juin à
juillet 1958 dans le château d'epône
mêmes je vais aller plus loin je vais
remonter jusqu'en 1791 les prémices de
la première constitution était écrite
iphone merci nicolas pour toutes ces
informations les dernières très rapide
très rapide une derrière le château de
versailles est bien évidemment coeur de
la monarchie absolue
avec le pouvoir politique voulue par
louis xiv et aujourd'hui encore le
château de versailles eh bien il ya le
congrès qui se réunit là-bas le congrès
sa réuni les 577 députés et les 348
sénateurs dans le cadre de la réforme
constitutionnelle la déclaration du
président de la république ou encore
pour autoriser un et à adhérer à l'union
européenne merci nicolas on aura appris
beaucoup m j'ai appris beaucoup sur
épaules je pensais pas merci pour toutes
ces informations on va parler à présent
emploi avait que deux invités qui nous
ont rejoints en plateau thomas gourland
bonsoir bonsoir avec le président de
l'agglomération rambouillet territoire
conseiller régional d'ile-de-france de
l'île de france est aussi président du
baça emploi formation du sud-ouest
francilien les acteurs de ce bassin se
sont réunis la semaine dernière pour
faire le point et un constat est
ressorti on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler dans un instant c'est qu'il ya
de la tension en matière de recrutement
dans le sud yvelines également philippe
cormier bonsoir vous êtes le directeur
du réseau entreprendre directeur
président j'ai un doute avec leur
directeur la bonne fonction on parlera
avec vous aussi du de la création
d'entreprise comment se porte cette
création d'entreprises dans les yvelines
ne vous posera la question tout à
l'heure je le disais donc thomas
gourland les services de l'état de la
région ile-de-france les entreprises les
représentants aussi est des quatre
intercommunalités de ce bassin emploi
formation du sud-ouest francilien se
sont réunis la semaine dernière alors
juste pour précisions le bassin emploi
formation du sud-yvelines regroupe
quatre territoires du sud ouest
francilien la communauté d'agglomération
de rambouillet territoire les
communautés de communes on va pouvoir
voir s'afficher peut-être l'animation ça
y est la voici est du pays où danet de
curd yvelines et aussi la communauté de
communes de la haute vallée de chevreuse
on précise qu'il existe quatre bassins
de ce type dans les yvelines 25 au total
en ile de france et ils ont été déployés
dès 2018 quels sont les objectifs des
bassins d'emploi monsieur canal et trois
objectifs le premier c'est de soutenir
l'émergence le développement des
activités économiques des territoires
que vous venez de citer le deuxième
sujet qui va nous occuper
particulièrement c'est faire rendre
l'adéquation entre l'offre et la demande
d'emploi la plus efficiente possible et
côté pragmatique de la chose est assez
fondamentale est le troisième sujet
assez classique au fond c'est de mettre
en synergie tous les acteurs économiques
des territoires pour pouvoir faire en
sorte que le développement se fasse le
plus facilement possible et ce bassin du
sud-ouest francilien compte 179 1641
habitants un chiffre qui date de 2018
pour environ 8 1980 demandeurs d'emploi
ça c'est un chiffre qui date et qui
datent de 2021 combien d'emplois à peu
près sur le territoire et quels sont les
secteurs qui emploient le plus justement
sur le territoire le territoire du sud
yvelines vous venez de citer donc je
voudrais de neuf mille demandeurs
d'emplois sur le territoire avec des
typologies assez différente maintenant
on a quelques secteurs qui sont
particulièrement en tension que nous
avons identifié le secteur des aides
soignants et des ados domicile plus de
400 demandes d'emploi offres d'emploi
sont faites sur le territoire anglais
deuxième sujet qui est un peu surprenant
en tout cas et moi qui m'avait surpris
c'est qu'on a près de 200 offres
d'emploi de conducteurs de transport
routier notamment sur la haute vallée de
chevreuse qui sont en souffrance et dont
on a difficulté a agréé et puis ensuite
d'autres spécificités territoriales dont
j'aurais peut-être l'occasion de vous
préciser les choses mais comment on peut
expliquer justement ces difficultés de
recrutement
est ce que la crise sanitaire et une
première explication est ce qu'elle a
changé la donne peut-être oui vous
faites très bien devenir de mentionner
parce que bon c'est des métiers qui sont
déjà par forcément extrait évident
exercé puis avait des contraintes
horaires assez forte avec des
contraintes aussi sanitaires et autres
mais nous constatons la partager avec
les présidents des ep si les entreprises
le coc vide a accéléré un show mutation
du rapport au travail d'une manière
générale et on constate que maintenant
le facteur qui permettrait un employé de
candidates et finalement ne sont plus
les mêmes qu'avant et le rapport entre
le travail et la vie de la vie
personnelle la vie à domicile le loisir
devient une variable qu'il faut
maintenant considéré d'une nouvelle
façon et l'attractivité de l'entreprise
doit s'adapter à cette nouvelle donne
cormier est ce que cette difficulté des
entreprises à recruter vous l'observez
aussi à l'échelle de tout le département
oui c'est enfin cette affaire en face et
qui a été accélérée géré depuis les
ducaux vide mais beaucoup de métiers
étaient déjà en fait attention au niveau
du recrutement on le voit en fait dans
différents secteurs d'activité et en
fait c'était le sujet le fil conducteur
de notre événement la semaine dernière à
savoir comment recruter et fidéliser un
traîneau talents d'aujourd'hui et de
demain
il ya eu un grand changement depuis deux
ans deux ans et demi en fait
on parle beaucoup de cadres à la quête
du sens en fait mais je pense que c'est
pas uniquement une question de
génération on constate aussi que c'est
vrai en fait au niveau désiré des cadres
ou des cadres supérieurs de 40 ans 45
ans donc c'est vraiment un sujet le
majeur et j'irai clés et surtout si on
parle de tpe start up tp au pm c'est un
vrai sujet de fond on accompagne aussi
un petit peu géré des entreprises et les
entrepreneurs ou les dirigeants
d'entreprise en fait sur le sujet de de
la marque employeur c'est souvent un
même mot utilisé en fait dans les
grandes entreprises mais finalement
c'est un sujet de fond fait pour les
petites structures et ça c'est un vrai
sujet parce que tant que l'entreprise
emploie ne va pas travailler en fait sur
sa stratégie il va pas pouvoir attirer
en fait les talents
donc c'est un sujet qu'il faut peut-être
retravailler au niveau de la marque et
reste on en parle beaucoup
quel projet entreprises en fait si on
veut attirer en fait des personnes s'est
pas encore j'irai des talents il faut
pouvoir avoir une belle image a raconté
donc c'est une question de perte
d'attractivité en fait au niveau des
entreprises il va parler la création
d'entreprise avec vous dans un instant
thomas bolland je le disais une
rencontre entre les différents acteurs
de ce bassin emploi formation avec aussi
des solutions qui ont été imaginés des
axes qui ont été identifiées pour
contrer justement cette tension en
matière de recrutement quels sont-ils et
les axes imaginez alors les axes imaginé
ça avec une approche très pragmatique
j'ai tendance à utiliser ce mot
régulièrement d'un duc tivité ou
d'induction c'est à dire on part du
terrain on parle la base par des besoins
des territoires et en créant construit
tous ensemble la solution nous avons
choisi d'expérimenter cette mise en
réseau de l'ensemble des acteurs
c'est-à-dire l'état la région
l'éducation nationale les présidents de
pci mais aussi tous les acteurs du
milieu de l'entreprise pour
traiter des cas pratiques donc nous
allons travailler sur les semaines qui
viennent sur les métiers du web au sens
général puisque sur le territoire que je
préside trois entreprises sont en grande
demande et on va pouvoir sur cet exemple
pratique mettre ensemble ces acteurs et
avec un objectif de créer une offre de
formation septembre 2023 donc l'objectif
est ambitieux mais on est tous sens en
rang pour pour y arriver ensemble il ya
aussi la vocation de clients guichet
unique ça c'est déjà en place c'est ça
alors le guichet unique c'est là un des
volets du bassin d'emploi c'est soutenir
ou l'émergence ou le développement
économique quel est le diagnostic que
j'ai pu faire depuis que je suis à la
région depuis un an maintenant c'est que
de nombreux dispositifs d'aidés aux
entreprises par les régions par l'état
par les opc ou voir l'europe sont
disponibles mais les entreprises n'y ont
pas accès tout simplement parce que la
technique juridico administratives aux
financières est tellement complexes
qu'elles ne le font pas et bien
rambouillet territoire se positionne
maintenant pour les aider c'est à dire
que nous faisons l'interface nous allons
voir les entreprises nous prenons acte
de leur volonté de développement et on
se charge de tout on monte les dossiers
on va saisir l'ensemble des instances on
va monter les dossiers les défendre de
manière à faire en sorte que les
subventions arrivent sur le territoire à
ce jour cinq entreprises sont contactés
pour un effet de levier potentiel de
près de cinq cent mille euros de
subventions aux balises de trois
entreprises quelles sont elles alors
pour raison de confidentialité je peux
pas vous les citer pour l'instant mais
cinq entreprises du territoire pour cinq
cent mille euros de subventions et on
précise aussi que la région ile de
france a débloqué 1 sur ce sujet de la
tension en matière de recrutement une
enveloppe d'un milliard d'euros on parle
aussi corner de la création d'entreprise
mais seulement exactement de la création
d'entreprise quels sont les secteurs où
la création foisonnent
comme vous pouvez le comprendre en fait
beaucoup coentreprise dans les métiers
numériques en fait développement
d'applications numériques digital
donc là il ya vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
de demandes
malheureusement en fait les projets sont
pas toujours suffisamment mature et les
réponses souvent les porteurs de projets
ne se rend pas compte que le numérique
en fait vous coûter très cher en termes
d'investissements sa part être
accessible dirait d'entrée de jeu mais
finalement fait pour développer une
activité une vraie entreprise en fait ça
demande énormément de fonds
d'investissement donc ça c'est un petit
peu le danger vous allez donner vos
conseils dans un instant j'ai une
question directe est ce que la création
d'entreprise se porte bien où justement
est-ce que la crise sanitaire est aussi
on sait un contexte d'inflation qui a
été créée aussi par par cette guerre en
ukraine et est ce qu'elle se porte bien
la création d'entreprise où justement il
ya des limites en ce moment non non ce
que ce qu'on a vu en fait un peu décalé
si je parle de pour les entreprises
ville en fête en 2021 on a eu 25 % de
contact de demandes entrantes
supplémentaires par rapport à 2020
sachant que 2020 malgré en fait la crise
qu vide en fait n'a pas baissé en termes
de créations d'entreprises donc ça nous
on a vécu 25 % et 1 et sur le même flux
en fait en 2022 donc est certainement
justement en fait des gens qui ont
réfléchi un petit peu pendant le coït se
poser plein de questions en fait sur
qu'est ce que je veux faire de ma vie la
quête du sens on y revient et se lance
en fait je dirais dans la création
d'entreprise sachant que le gouvernement
les détails les régions ile-de-france
enfin donne beaucoup de moyens pour
aider en fait les porteurs de projets à
créer leur propre entreprise on est
alors pour bénéficier de ce réseau
entreprendre comment est ce qu'on fait
qu et quelles sont les démarches à
suivre alors nous on a notre virée notre
leitmotiv en fait c'est d'accompagner
des entreprises déjà entreprises en fait
qu'ils ont vraiment une ambition à se
développer et il fait n'est créé
d'emplois en fait sur le territoire sera
combien dans l'année dans la ligue on
est sur des promotions d'une vingtaine
d'entreprises donc on a des critères
d'éligibilité dont un critère difficulté
qui est important savoir que
l'entreprise doit créer idéalement
quatre à cinq ans pour à trois ans cinq
à huit emplois à 5 ans donc pas se dire
qu'on est quand même sélection
littéraire assez forte mais quand on
regarde les statistiques en fait on
s'aperçoit que les entreprises qu'on
accompagne en création à 5-6 ans
d'existence créé huit à neuf emplois
donc en fait on est vraiment dans nos
objectifs et je parle pas en fait de
l'accompagnement des reprises
d'entreprises ont une artiste vous
parlez des quelques conseils le premier
conseil à donner pour les porteurs de
projets qui nous regardent c'est d'abord
de penser bien réfléchir bien construire
ce projet c'est facile à dire mais c'est
peut-être aussi par les droits y avoir
en fait une multitude de
conseils sur avec le premier pour moi
qui est vraiment important c'est avant
de se lancer d'aller voir en fait ces
futurs clients et s'assurer en fait j'ai
vraiment un besoin donc et que j'irai le
projet la solution via le produit qu'on
souhaite apporter correspond à des
attentes et on peut créer en fait la
marche est donc ça c'est le premier le
premier conseil parce qu'on s'aperçoit
que en fait avec l'historique on voit
que la girelle à une des raisons
majeures en fait des difficultés des
échecs dans la création c'est un manque
d'appétence et de compétences
commerciales on est souvent trop de
focaliser sur son produit solution se
rend pas compte vraiment donné il va
falloir quand même le commercialiser il
va falloir quand même le monde et
deuxième conseil c'est de se faire
accompagner par les entreprises divine
ou par d'autres j'irai organisme parce
que la vie est un crédit d'entreprise
est extrêmement difficile déjà il faut
pas être dans cette démarche bonsoir
serez accompagné en complément aussi
j'aimerais peut-être recherche sont
associés pour avoir géré une
complémentarité au niveau des
compétences et de l'expérience c'est
vraiment très très bon le site internet
du réseau entreprendre yvelines qui va
s'afficher en bas de l'écran pour vous
contacter avoir toutes les informations
merci à vous philippe cormier directeur
de ce réseau et merci à vous thomas
gourland je rappelle conseiller régional
d'île de france également président de
l'agglomération rambouillet territoire
on continue cette émission ma selle on
va parler de pouvoir d'achat et patrick
jacq de disputes nous rejoint un plateau
bonsoir
[Musique]
vous allez nous donner des astuces pour
réduire notre facture énergétique
essayer parce que c'est la crise voilà à
bamako jours nicolas justin gorille
mathilde monsieur bonjour donc alors
donc j'ai prévu en fait le côté un peu
parfois onéreux mais bon pour isoler
sont la meilleure des solutions en fait
pour isoler sa maison et pour faire des
vraies économies c'est d'isoler la
maison et de juste d'avoir un mode de
chauffage est vraiment très intéressant
juste et
donc pour ça vous avez des êtres de
l'état qui existent il faut se
renseigner sur les sites appropriés pour
trouver ces aides parce que c'est un
poste qui va être cher mais aussi les
aides qui sont cumulables il ya ma prime
rénove c'est la première aide je sais
parce que j'ai été dans les dossiers a
très récemment coeur mais on peut
cumuler les aides d'accord mais
effectivement je crois que c'était pour
leurs fenêtres vous c'est simple pas
seulement
donc il faut savoir quand même que isolé
par exemple ses combles ou de sa maison
de l'extérieur ça permet de faire des
économies jusqu'à 25% de d'économie de
déperdition de chaleur et donc fait d
une économie d'environ 250 euros par an
et alors il ya la pompe à chaleur qui
elle est très intéressante assez
coûteuse effectivement mais elle va
remplacer la pompe la chaudière
traditionnel pardon
et va vous réduit de 50 à 70 % les
dépenses énergétiques liées au chauffage
il vous permet d'économiser d'économiser
700 euros par un coup de pompe et dans
le porte-monnaie composite façon pour
les choses du coup patrick serait
l'astuce la moins coûteuse à mettre en
place alors les petites choses à faire
par exemple si on prend dont on va dans
le salon
l'utilisation d'une multiprise à
interrupteur vous permettra d'étendre en
une seule fois toutes les alimentations
les boks les télés les ifi les consoles
les parts de son les gens passent et on
peut en trouver jusqu'à 15 à 5 ans dans
une maison des appareils qui restent en
veille selon l'ademe et ça peut coûter
jusqu'à 30 à 80 euros par an juste pour
le petit bled allumés dans la maison
et le sud est voilà avec une multiprise
on est un tout ça est alors le but aussi
ce serait de supprimer toutes les
ampoules halogènes je sais qu'il y en a
encore dans les foyers pour le moment
est de tout passer aux lettres parce que
c'est 85 % d'économie jusqu'à 150 euros
de d'économies par an ça c'est dans le
salon mais aussi dans la cuisine on peut
avoir si quelques quelques gestes voilà
qui peut être serait un détail pour vous
mais qui pourrait aussi dire beaucoup
cette chanson
alors du coup je veux pas la chanter
mais bon effectivement il faudrait
privilégier dans l'idéal
l'électroménager de classe à vous savez
ces petites ces petites barres
énergétiques qui vont de a à g donc le à
c'est le plus économe pour tous les
appareils si c'est possible ça a un coût
mais bon ça fait des économies
alors mettre un couvercle sur ses
casseroles c'est 30% d'économies au
niveau là c'est plus rapide et l'on fait
des économies voilà alors concernant le
frigo et le congélateur et 2 chose à
savoir c'est que idéalement il faut pour
décongeler
mettre les aliments au frigo parce que
comme celle frigo et judy voilà il reste
il ya sept ans après chasse et voilà bon
ça demande un peu d'anticipation c'est
très étonnant jeu par justin non
c'est pas méchant vous savez que vous
allez bien donc du coup pour le frigo
aussi on trouve souvent dans un
congélateur dans le frigo une petite
pellicule de
las de glace voilà très très très
mauvais une fois qu'elle dépasse les 3
mm on peut aller jusqu'à 30 % de
consommation d'électricité en plus sur
ces appareils ces propos du nord voilà
donc alors pour le
pour l'heure toujours en cuisine pour
réchauffer les plats et les petits
restes de la veille du film on peut il
vaut mieux utiliser le micro onde parce
que c'est plus rapide et c'est moins
énergivore que le four parce qu'il faut
savoir que le fourreau hui à la selle
champion du monde de la maison en terme
d'énergie et il vous en coûte environ
entre 10 et 15 centimes d'euros par
heure pour le faut c'est un gros pot ce
niveau
alors pensez à atteindre le four et la
musique électrique un tout petit peu
avant la fin de la cuisson si c'est
impossible puisqu'il n'y a pas de
petites économies
petite astuce ingénieuse pour terminer
patrick est gratuite peut-être et qui
sont gratuites alors le chauffe-eau le
chauffe eau sur une température on le
met sur la température de 50 à 60 à 60
degrés c'est pas la peine d'aller plus
haut c'est 20 % d'économies coupé le
chauffage quand on s'absente pendant une
semaine où le chauffe-eau aussi
évidemment il faut que le chauffe eau
il faut savoir que le chauffe-eau bardon
est sur la deuxième marche du podium des
plus gros consommateurs de la maison
toujours à la maison fermée et ouvrez
les bleus les volets et les rideaux vous
permettra de garder ou d'évacuer la
chaleur en fonction de la saison même si
on double vitrage dans la maison le fait
d'ouvrir de jongler que les collèges
suis pas si vieux il ya trop de soleil
oui voilà
alors pour le robinet les robinets d'eau
froide quand on se lave les mains il
faut savoir que c'est pas la peine
d'aller le temps qu'on se lave les mains
c'est très très rapide on vient l'accord
souvent mais l'eau chaude mais une chose
n'est pas arrivé et on a déjà fini se
laver les mains donc prenons le réflexe
de nous laver les mains à l'eau froide
voilà et alors que un dernier conseil
peut-être dans les conseils ça va être
des tables et lumière dans les pièces
inoccupées comme de la glue dit on est à
côté on n'a pas à versailles ici on n'a
pas la salle voilà est alors le devenez
petits conseils c'est pour le lave linge
c'est de laver à basse température 30 40
degrés pas plus et éviter les programmes
consommateurs rapide qui vont venir
voilà bien chargé
voila voila merci patrick pour ce
conseil
donc c'est important ça c'est important
tous les petits je stocke pas que tous
les porte-monnaie exactement
merci en tout cas pour tous ces conseils
patrick un portrait à présent avec vous
justin vous êtes allés à la rencontre
d'une malvoyantes elle essaye de
combiner ses études avec son handicap et
vous êtes allé à aller à sa rencontre
exactement en fait j'ai fait donc comme
vous l'avez la rencontre récente de
cécile elle a 27 ans et c'est une jeune
femme dont qui est malvoyante et qui
actuellement en première année de
gestion donc c'est à lui vécu à
l'université versailles saint quentin et
donc elle a mis en place aux alentours
de l'université a mis en place des
aménagements pour les personnes qui sont
atteintes de handicap etc s'il dispose
également l2 d'outils personnel l'idée
dans ce témoignage c'était de nous
expliquer comment jouer entre ses études
et son handicap et je vous propose de
découvrir ça
vu les problèmes qu'on a de
discrimination dans le monde
étudiants ont finalement je veux même
pas voir ce que ça va donner dans le
monde du travail et je veux pouvoir
travailler enfin créer mon emploi et
adapter mon poste en fait à moi même et
ça du coup ça me fait un objectif cécile
à 27 ans elle est atteinte de déficience
visuelle dut informatique master 1 de
japonais est actuellement première année
de licence de gestion a lu vs q cela
fait 9 ans qu'elle apprend pas facile de
jongler avec les études quand on est
malvoyant fatigue visuelle importantes
difficultés de perception des détails ou
encore de déplacement un combat de tous
les jours on se repère avec le sol
différent par rapport aux autres
en fait il ya les difficultés par
rapport aux études donc suivre les cours
prendre des notes réussir les examens à
voir les aménagements il ya aussi les
dix les difficultés liées aux
déplacements trouver les salles où on
accourt ne pas se tromper dans les
emplois du temps parfois on n'arrive pas
à lier une lignée du contrôle horaire 11
tonnes de sel pas du coup c'est assez
pratique ici parce que dans cette
université il ya des accueils dans
chacun des bâtiments ce qu'il n'y a pas
dans toutes les universités et ça quand
on trouve pas ni salle c'est quand même
vraiment très pratique michel aulas l'a
pas mal à ça c'est le genre de truc
qui est un peu compliqué parce qu'aux ne
les détecte pas avec la can et je sais
pas où je peux passer du coup
des petits pièges comme sa surprise que
va pas calculer à chaque fois alors
normalement l'amphi 1 et par ici un
équilibre entre travail et fatigue est
pas toujours facile à trouver pour aider
les personnes en situation de handicap
l'université met en place des
aménagements comme cet ascenseur cécile
dispose également d'outils personnel une
canne pour les déplacements une loupe
électronique ou encore cet ipad qui lui
permet d'accéder à une synthèse vocale
et décriront contraste inversé c'est que
mon texte est écrit en blanc sur fond
noir comme ça c'est beaucoup moins
éblouissant pour les yeux quand on passe
beaucoup de temps sur l'écran mais je
pense qu'il n'ya pas que les personnes
malveillantes pour qui c'est confortable
la c6 un de mes cours que j'ai tapé
sous la dictée donc c'est pour ça qu'il
est assez complexe quand les profs ne
font peut dicter mois-ci ce qu'ils
mangent le plus c'est que mes camarades
râle parce qu'ils aiment bien précis
avec des choses écrites mois celle
inverse
voiceover activé drive clientèle métier
de produits voilà il y en at il dit
après les produits le courant le par
exemple que j'ai sélectionné les visages
après je peux re désactiver assez
facilement quand j'ai eu besoin de lire
un texte qui est tout petit je peux
cliquer sur l'élément et faire lire par
l'ipad prend vraiment c'est assez
pratique il est il espère sensibiliser
pour faire comprendre son handicap
aujourd'hui le manque d'informations
dont disposent ses camarades impact sa
vie étudiante ne sachant pas comment
réagir ils n'osent pas venir vers elle
un regret pour la jeune femme pourtant
très sociable mes camarades à
l'université sont bloqués par ça mais je
pense pas que ce soit forcément de la
mauvaise volonté ou c'est juste qu'ils
savent pas comment venir vers moi ils
savent pas
comment s'adresser à moi je suis non
voyantes ou malvoyantes 6 et du coup je
suis très souvent tout seul et je pense
que c'est assez triste en fait deux
désir moi j'adore échanger avec les gens
j'adore discuter et se retrouver tout
seul tout le temps juste parce que les
gens ils savent pas on peut être
et c'est vraiment dommage parce que
quand on est étudiant on est là aussi
pour échanger vous-même enfin juste
aller manger avec des gens quelque part
allaient discuter dès pour discuter et
c'est très très rare que je puisse
parler avec des gens donc c'est un peu
un peu dommage au terme de ses études
cécile a pour objectif de créer sa
propre entreprise dans l'import de
produits japonais
mais c'est une rencontre touchante
justin qu'est ce qui vous a plu dans le
tournage de ce reportage alors comme
vous l'a dit c'était vraiment touchant
et très enrichissant pour moi j'ai
vraiment aimé ce tomber ce reportage
parce qu'en fait si elle est vraiment
très sociable et dynamique elle est
souriante vous avez pu le voir et est en
fait l'idée c'est quand même un combat
de tous les jours pour elle est donc en
fait on se rend pas tous les jours qu'on
feint nous on se rend pas compte
forcément mais c'est énormément de défis
et pourtant le prince avec le sourire et
elle avait beaucoup d'humour là dessus
et en fait malgré les aménagements il
malgré les outils voilà faut toujours se
battre exemple pour avoir un tiers-temps
des fois et puis quand on a une personne
qui est un handicap par exemple pour la
malvoyance tout le monde réagit pas
pareil donc c'est compliqué d'expliquer
à un prof par exemple bas qui comprend
pas moi j'avais ça fait ça pour une
personne malvoyante et vous voulez je
réagissent différemment on comprend pas
toujours nokia beaucoup de
sensibilisation à faire et c'est pour ça
qu'elle a voulu faire ce témoignage et
je voudrais juste insister sur quelque
chose qui m'a profondément touché c'est
qu'on n'ose pas forcément enfin les
personnes en tout cas de de l'inertie
n'ose pas aller vers elle parce qu'ils
ne savent pas comment réagir et en fait
c'est triste parce qu'elle aimerait
justement et ça dérange pas d'en parler
et elle aimerait vraiment que les gens
viennent vers elle parce que voilà c'est
pas un tabou et et elle est ravi
d'expliquer si besoin le vivre cette vie
étudiante en fait donc n'hésitez pas si
vous avez des personnes
des collègues ou des camarades atteints
de handicaps à aller vers eux mais je
pense que c'est le mieux qu'on puisse
faire pour ça j'ai passé ce qui reste
avec nous exactement vous allez nous
représenter pour les téléspectateurs qui
n'étaient pas avec nous dès le début de
cette émission les infos à retenir dans
les yvelines avec notamment la députée
lebron privé qui vient d'être élue
présidente de l'assemblée nationale mais
c'est la première femme à occuper donc
cette fonction une information mise en
avant dans son discours je cite il aura
fallu attendre près d'un demi siècle
pour que les premières femmes rentrent
dans cet hémicycle le vote a eu lieu
hier mardi 28 juin ayez le brevet a été
élu à l'issue du second tour avec 242
voix elle succède ainsi à richard
ferrand les restos du coeur qui ont un
nouveau centre il vient d'être inauguré
à magnanville et si le central ouvert
ses portes en février 2022 il a été
inauguré ce mercredi 29 juin un bilan
depuis son ouverture 730 personnes
accueillies régulièrement pour une
moyenne de 3000 repas distribués chaque
semaine à noter que le centre fermera
ses portes pour l'été mais leur ouvrira
le 6 septembre et autres infos à retenir
ce sont les habitants de poissy qui
connaîtront leur nouveau maire bientôt
oui puisque suite à l'élection de karl
olive en tant que député de la 12e
circonscription aux élections
législatives et puis face à la règle de
non cumul des mandats ce dernier doit
céder sa place elle le conseil municipal
de poissy se réunira dimanche à l'hôtel
de ville pour élire donc le nouveau
maire et ses sons actuels première
adjointe sandrine dos santos qui devrait
lui succéder bien merci beaucoup justin
pour ces informations à retenir nous
avons été rejoints en plateau par julie
durouchoux bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
habitante de noisy le roi bonsoir et
vous êtes avec régis duval vous êtes le
vice-président de l'association alors
c'est assez de bn c'est bien ça c'est
assez 2d assez de haine de sécurité
bonjour tout aux auditeurs mais c'est
une association
de vigilance sur les qualités de
l'environnement de vie
ce n'est pas une association qui fait du
militantisme en quoi que ce soit c'est
un cadre dans lequel les gens qui m'ont
souci de qualité de vie non alors en
vienne vienne se regrouper pour essayer
de faire avancer les choses et alors en
ce moment votre combat c'est ce nouveau
tram train d'être aide et là encore en
phase de test mais il sera lancé le 6
juillet il redira notamment à saint cyr
l'école à saint germain en laye et
passera donc par les communes de noisy
le roi et bailly et alors tous les deux
enfin même avec les autres habitants des
communes vous allez faire un constat il
fait trop de bruit notamment vous julie
en fait le tram train passe à 20 mètres
de chez vous très concrètement en fait
au bout de votre jardin tout à fait donc
du coup je voulais savoir comment
c'était si vous aviez passé un bon week
end
là également j'ai passé un excellent
week-end et vous savez pourquoi parce
qu'en fait le train tram n'a pas circulé
ce week end donc on était tranquille
donc c'est aujourd'hui ce qu'ont
constaté les habitants et riverains de
cette ligne qui a été vendu donc aux
habitants comme un tramway est donc le
tramway c'est tout ce que s'est dit mme
ding
il ya des nuisances sonores qui sont
engendrées caractéristiques en fait d'un
train donc effectivement on a bien parlé
d'un tram train donc effectivement dans
le monde étudiant cahier des charges est
de toute façon dans la mémoire de tous
il est logique qu'un tramway circulent
en ville et qu'un train circule en
campagne donc il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui nous nos habitats on
habite les villes de noisy ben ali c'est
un peu l'état d'esprit village on habite
entre la forêt la plaine de versailles
c'est un environnement extrêmement calme
où on enregistre un niveau de décibels
on vient on vit entre 30 et 40 décibels
et donc tout d'un coup ce qu'on nous
propose c'est toutes les dix minutes
donc dans les deux sens toutes les cinq
minutes plus tôt c'est de faire passer
un train à 100 km heure avec des pics
jusqu'à 80 décibels donc des études ont
montré lors gérer jc plus fort des
études montrent que en augmentant très
peu les décibels 5 à 10 décibels tout de
suite ça nous c'est le double 1 ça nous
paraît le double là on parle de 40 à 80
décibels donc vous imaginez un petit peu
le désarroi des habitants les fréquences
alors
évidemment tous ont rappelé qu on est
ravi merci pour vos voilà pour la
suppression du tram-train parce que
c'est un moyen de transport qui emprunte
du réseau urbain comme un tramway mais
aussi du réseau ferré c'est pour ça
qu'on parle de tram train voilà alors
c'est pour ça qu'il est aussi bruyant
parce qu'ils empruntent le réseau ferré
et que le matériel est adapté aux
réseaux ferrés donc il siffle et
j'entends siffler le train on continue
mais voilà pour le coup tout le monde
l'entend sifflé dès 5h30 du matin sur
les premiers passages jusqu'à 00h30 le
soir donc ce qui fait une plage assez
courte de sommeil ça réveille tous les
habitants dans leur sommeil depuis les
eaux de noisy où j'habite jusqu'en bas
de ben ali
jusqu'au dernier résidence à vent de
travers de retraverser voilà le
l'autoroute donc voilà ce qui provoque
aujourd'hui la colère des riverains et
c'est surtout en fait le sentiment
d'avoir été floués ont dit tous oui au
tram on souhaite être respectée au même
titre que les habitants de saint germain
en laye de saint cyr avec une
circulation du tram tramway donc sur des
vitesses sur des vitesses raisonnables
de tramo et et que le train à y circuler
en rase campagne et il faut savoir
également ce qui est important on parle
de nuisances sonores à cause de la
vitesse de ce train n'en parle également
de sécurité puisque ce train circule
avec des pics à 80 km/heure en pleine
ville où les voitures c'est un milieu
urbain les voitures sont limités à 50
km/heure et ils circulent jusqu'à ce en
kilomètres heure en bord de résidence
d'un côté j'ai le train qui circule à
100 alors que de l'autre côté on est
limité à 30 km à
6 km a bien compris vos attentes je me
dis d une une réunion publique avec
notamment la député de la 3e
circonscription béatrice pire ronde les
deux maire de bailly et de noisy le roi
pour parler de ces nuisances sonores
également étaient présents ile-de-france
mobilité et la sncf alors comment s'est
passée cette réunion régis est ce que
vous avez eu le sentiment d'être entendu
non
le constat que nous pouvons tirer c'est
que
du côté de france mobilité alors qu'un
projet de ce type là qui est la création
d'une nouvelle ligne ça n'arrive quand
même pas tous les ans en région
parisienne
c'est un grand projet ça intéresse des
milliers de personnes
ça doit être l'objet d'une véritable
ambition à la fois sociales
économiques et environnementales
le constat que nous faisons c'est que
oui c'est un projet avec une ambition
économique nous retiendrons là dessus
mais en terme environnemental pour les
rives pas du tout nous devons trouver
absolument aucune écoute du côté des de
france mobilité qui s'accroche à deux
critères qui sont extrêmement simples
c'est le premier la vitesse est critique
pour l'économie du projet donc ça c'est
leurs arguments et deuxièmement la
demande de limitation qui est formulée
par les riverains on peut résumer
grossièrement à
limiter la vitesse à 30 35 km heure dans
le secteur dans toute cette zone
urbanisée qui est complètement
urbanisées puisque la ligne pour une
moitié parce qu'en plein à l'intérieur
des villes de bégué et noisy et sur le
reste du trajet elle est complètement
mitoyenne des habitations qui comme qui
sont installés à partir de verre mètres
de la ligne on va vous demander de
conclure très vite parce qu'on va
écouter aussi de france mobilité sur la
question à la ssii dont il n'y a pas
cette ambition là les 80 décibels qui
ont été évoquées il faut comprendre que
c'est le niveau de bruit du périphérique
1 ce qui est demandé cela permet de
réduire de ramener ce niveau de bruit à
quelque chose de tolérable
ce que produit un train c'est un passage
qui va être de 20 à 25 à 30 secondes en
fonction de la vitesse et vous avez le
bruit d'un aspirateur en pleine
puissance pendant 30 secondes toutes les
cinq minutes c'est comme ça qu'il faut
comprendre les chiffres qui ont été
avancés vous avez parlé des décibels on
a également contacté ile-de-france
mobilité comme le disait grégory et
justement elle ne faisait pas requise à
lire réaliser une nouvelle étude sonore
je vous propose d'écouter grégoire de
lasteyrie vice président d'ile-de-france
mobilité je vais vous donner quelques
références parce que quand on parle de
décibels on se rend pas forcément ça
veut dire quelqu'un qui tombe sur gazon
c'est 90 décibels une voiture qui passe
à quelques mètres de vous dans la rue
c'est 70 décibels une conversation comme
celle qu'on est en train d'avoir vous et
moi maintenant c'est 60 décibels et dans
un appartement normal calme en général
on est à 45 10 semaines l'objectif qu'on
s'est fixé sur le tram-train traits sont
des objectifs très ambitieux parce que
en journée on a demandé de ne pas
dépasser les 60 3 décibels c'est à dire
- sort qu'une voiture qui roule dans la
rue et la nuit d'être inférieure à 50 8
décibels c'est à dire être inférieur à
une conversation normale de deux
personnes donc vous voyez c'est quand
même des choses qui sont assez assez
exigeante tant que c'est ça qu'on va
vérifier je peux pas vous donner encore
plus que la l'étude est en cours et à
propos de la vitesse pour grégoire de la
série serait compliqué de la réduire
pour des raisons financières et des
traîtres d'attractivité de la ligne on
écoute à nouveau
si on décide de limiter la vitesse du
thé 13 à 30 km heure déjà il faut
démontrer que à 30 km arrivée - de loïc
que à 70,60 parce que finalement le
passager plus long aussi et donc la
nuisance sonore réelles de plus dans la
dans la durée et on peut avoir certains
types de crissements qui sont tout aussi
fort à à 34,70 souka à 100 km heure ça
rajouterait plus de cinq minutes et
demie de temps de trajet sur sur le
titre s et 17% plus de temps de trajet
quand on va d'un point à 20 du terminus
d'un terminus à l'autre de la ligne donc
on rendrait la ligne moins attractive et
surtout on ne serait pas du coup en
capacité de continuer à faire un tram
train toutes les 10 minutes en heure de
pointe sans devoir acheter du nouveau
matériel roulant pas ce qui évidemment
ça demandera d'avoir plus de train train
mobilisés pour pouvoir faire la même
distance et pour vous donner une idée
une rame supplémentaire ses coûts de six
millions d'euros nous avons donc
entendue grégoire de lasteyrie vice
président d'ile-de-france mobilité alors
le temps nous est compté malheureusement
c'est julie est ce que les arguments que
grégoire de lasteyrie a avancé est ce
que ce sont des arguments que vous vous
entendez ou pas pas du tout d'ailleurs
nous contestons de totalité des chiffres
qui ont été avancés par l'ile-de-france
mobilité premier point sur les 63 des
béquilles ont été avancées par grégoire
de lasteyrie ce sont ces une valeur
moyenne sur la totalité des heures de
circulation 6h à 22h c'est à dire que
vous faites une moyenne entre deux
périodes de bruit et des périodes willy
rien du tout alors que la réalité du
bruit quand il parlait de voiture c'est
une voiture qui passe pas quand une
voiture n'est pas là donc ils comparent
un chou et une carotte pour parler de
niveau de bruit expliqué que 63 tb c'est
très bien
deuxièmement ils disent à un impact
économique très important parce que en
fait c'est un impact sur le temps de
circulation globale de la ligne les
chiffres qui ont été montrées le 21 juin
en réunion publique ile-de-france
mobilité sont complètement fantaisistes
ce qu'ils ont parlé de huit minutes 19
secondes pour le temps de transfert de
référence le temps de circulation sur
les 3 km 200 que fait la zone urbanisée
d'oublier une musique je vous passe les
détails mais ça fait à peu près 6032
circulation ce qui veut dire que le
train qu'ils ont mesuré parce qu'ils
prétendent que ce sont des mesures en
fait rouler un maximum de 25 km h de
moyenne alors que en réalité il grimpe à
70 80 km donc ça serait bien que
monsieur lasteyrie avant de reprendre
les éléments de communication technique
du sens donné par ses services les
examine un petit peu par lui même pour
se rendre compte qu'ils sont en plus
complètement incohérent très bon
pionnier panel pas chaud le mot de la
fin vous revient quelles sont vos
attentes aujourd'hui en quelques mois il
a écouté vie des habitants ont été assez
clair nous on a assisté à toute cette
réunion
nous à un petit peu endormi à base de
mesures qui vont être prises peut-être
en septembre et c'est pour nous en fait
il est clairement intolérable que se
trame commence à rouler à la vitesse où
il a été prévu donc en fait
effectivement sur toute une zone
d'agglomération et une zone urbaine on
demande à ce que les limitations de
vitesse réglementaire soit appliquée
voilà et là dessus on serait intraitable
c'est sûr donc on préférerait venir
faire la fête avec tout le monde le 6
juillet à l'univers l'inauguration mais
si c'est pas le cas on viendra peut-être
bien celle à fait ce qui est dommage
d'ailleurs parce que tout le monde est
très content de voir l'arrivée de ce
tram mais le manque à gagner de la
vitesse c'est cinq minutes je sais pas
si vous êtes tous nés vous avez grandi
en yvelines mais ici en fait on n'a pas
été habitué à être à cinq minutes près
dans les transports en commun merci
julie et régis ce sera le mot de la fin
on suivra ce dossier de très près merci
d'avoir été avec lyon rappelle l'arrivée
du train t13 mise en service le 6
juillet entre saint cyr l'école et saint
germain est alors si vous nous rejoignez
vous n'avez vous avez manqué les 48
premières minutes de cette émission on a
parlé de politique d'emploi de pouvoir
d'achat ne soyez pas ne soyez pas
inquiet vous pouvez retrouver le replay
de cette émission bien sûr sur notre
site internet on va entamer maintenant
une page sports va revenir aussi sur les
40 ans du centre alfred de vigny à
voisins le bretonneux et on parlera
également dans un instant de la fée des
loges on aura l'occasion de monter en
manège enfin les journalistes de la
rédaction sont montés dans les manèges
de la fête des loges d'un beau programme
que nous avons alors on va débuter cette
fin d'émission on arrive petit à petit à
la fin d'émission avec le tour de france
bixente mayence insisté ban est allé à
la rencontre de capucine loriot elle est
comédienne mais travaille également dans
l'événementiel sportif depuis trois ans
sur les routes du tour de france elle
occupe pour la première fois cette année
le poste d'animatrice speakerine sur la
première caravane tourtel twist de
l'histoire du tour regardez cette
découverte de ce métier
[Musique]
mine de rien ces trois semaines pendant
six heures non stop je vais parler aux
spectateurs donc il faut pas perdre la
voix
c'est des réveils en général vers 6h 7h
du matin maximum classé incroyable il ya
toutes les caravanes publicitaires donc
c'est génial c'est le moment un peu où
on rencontre du monde on prépare bien
sûr nos véhicules donc ça c'est quand
même le plus important - en tant
qu'animatrice du coup voilà je vais bien
installé mon micro faire des essais son
volume et cetera bien-être accroché on
est quand même ce qu'il faut savoir
qu'on est sur le tour voilà c'est des
routes quand même de montagne sera donc
qu'on est quand même libre donc faut
être bien accroché
nous on est en avant en amour des
coureurs et on fait du coup tout le
parcours moi mon rôle ça va être
justement de parler de tourtes et twist
dire aux spectateurs que les caravanes
arrive qu'on va distribuer j'ai un micro
toute la journée je vais m'adresser à
aux spectateurs donc il ya toujours une
petite pression par rapport à ça après
voilà moi du coup je vais représenter
tourtel twist j'ai rencontré justement
les directeurs et qui sont vraiment très
sympa donc l'ambiance générale fait que
ça détend forcément aussi
[Musique]
ça me croyable les gens ils sont super
contents d'être là moi je dis que je
rencontre des personnes même dans la vie
de tous les jours je leur dis que je
fais le tour de france ils sont super
contents ils disent tous ça mais nous on
a hâte on a découvert le parcours on
sera sur telle route
tourmalet l'étape du tourmalet c'est
franchement c'est plein d'avis chaque
fois qu'on y va du coup j'ai fait deux
en deux ans on y aller c'est très commun
comme parcours c'est magnifique
franchement
dudit départ à huy la montée du col
c'est incroyable s'est plaint mais j'ai
vraiment je conseille à tous mondial
leader
[Musique]
dans plusieurs personnes qui nous ont
rejoint un plateau et notamment celui
qui a réalisé cette interview bixente
mais un santisteva noir bixente bonsoir
vente amateurs de sport et de cyclisme
on l'a dit le tour de france qu'il est
mort vendredi il passera par les
yvelines pas de départ pas de dernière
étape au départ de des yvelines ça
partira cette dernière étape depuis
paris la défense arina passage par la
plaine de versailles à quelques jours du
tout est ce que vous avez déjà votre
favori je pense que on peut tout se dire
que t'as d'beaux gatcha est le favori de
cette année avec le mowgli douala ils
vont se disputer
le tour le général on peut revenir sur
les français peut-être qui eux ont
quelque chance de l'homme a pas de gêne
y aura là philippe mais il ya un
français qui s'est acquis a déclaré
vouloir jouer le général
c'est david gaudieux de l'équipe
groupama fdj qui sera emmené aussi on
pense par thibaut pinot qui a déjà joué
le général du tour de france on a aussi
par exemple aurait une bar gay qui
concourra pour gagner des étapes florent
chesnais sénéchal le récent champion de
france qui pourra peut-être tenter sa
chance voilà sur la cinquième étape à
arenberg avec le retour des pavés après
quatre ans pour de france alors on
poursuit cette page sports avec vous
bixente alors vous allez nous parler
d'une autre discipline ça se passe au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines mais ce n'est pas du vélo en
effet mathieu je sais pas si vous êtes
balader aux alentours du vélodrome en
fin de semaine dernière mais vous avez
dû remarquer une petite différence
d'habitude on croise voilà des profils
type cycliste 50 kg environ
profil fin ils ont été remplacés par une
sorte d'exposition d'armoire à glace de
frigo et autre mobilier d'intérieur bien
musclé bien galbées et pour cause en
fait du 24 au 26 juin avec lui une
compétition internationale de crossfit
est ce que vous savez ce que c'est le
crossfit plus ou moins j'ai déjà vu la
muscu hardcore
c'est le même officiellement ce sont des
mouvements fonctionnel constamment
variés et exécuté à haute intensité en
réalité de l'extérieur même si vous avez
raison ça ressemble plus à une torture
infligée à soi même gratuitement
regardez ce petit extrait
[Musique]
donc voilà on peut vraiment lire la
souffrance sur leur visage et qui dit
compétition internationale du biceps
venus d'espagne quadriceps italien
deltoïde irakien et même trapèze de
corée du sud mais on a cherché fouillé
et on a retrouvé quelques saint
quentinois parmi la foule qui
participait à la con à la compétition
lauren mathon par exemple regardez
jean c'est vraiment car et du coup il
n'y a pas trop de retard et on attend à
des créneaux on passe alors du créneau
c'est le plus gros événement coïncidant
fassions venir ici ça ressemble défis
qui ont vraiment la niaque et du niveau
qu'en envie de se battre et tu peux pas
c'est pour ça que je suis là possible
donc ça s'appelle attention mon accent
anglais le cros film french trop dingue
c'est un événement annuel comme tout
événement annuel grégory sa dernière
édition avait lieu en c'était sûrement
avant la crise sanitaire jérémy 19 ans
là comme tout événement annuel ça a été
repoussé de deux ans pendant trois jours
on a dénombré sept cents sportifs et
4000 à 5000 spectateurs on écoutait
julian fesseur le directeur qui nous en
dit plus sur l'organisation de l'hiver
vous avez plusieurs phases la première
c'est une phase de qualifications qui se
fait en ligne en général en février à
mars une fois qu'ils sont qualifiés qui
peuvent s'inscrire pour la finale et ils
viennent à la finale sur trois jours ils
vont avoir une pac ait des preuves donc
une multitude d'épreuves différentes
pour les élites les meilleurs
compétiteurs de la discipline ici ils
vont avoir neuf épreuves l'idée c'est de
tester toutes leur condition physique
donc on va avoir des choses en stricte
des choses longue des choses moyennes la
course ou à soulever des charges on va
essayer de les tester surtout surtout
les schémas possibles de mouvement et de
fonctionnalités si vous voulez donc
voilà pour les épreuves c'était soit en
solo soit par équipe de quatre pour
quatre fois plus de souffrance pour
avoir fait le tour et vu les différentes
épreuves c'est un sport vraiment complet
il y a du poids de corps du lever de
poids du foncier de l'endurance du tir
au pistolet de l'effort cours de
l'effort l'ont toujours avec une grosse
musique de fond des grosses bases pour
bien se motiver bien rentrés dans un
état d'exaltation un sport idéal pour
entretenir condition physique santé
confiance en soi en tout cas moi ça m'a
donné envie de commencer à préparer mon
sonore body grégory machi et essai sur
sur cet événement il fallait de
professionnels il fallait vraiment être
déjà rage parce que j'aurais été bien
ridicule me
suis en plein exercice je pense que
revenu l'été ce sera peut-être participe
à la prochaine édition l'accent anglais
était bon jeu mais le souligner car si
vicente bravo pour cette chronique et
nous avons fait découvert le crossfit
qui qui se développe ou on attend alors
que la démonstration
est donc avec nous célia vous nous avez
rejoint en plateau bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir à tous bonjour nous parler du
centre alfred de vigny à voisins le
bretonneux parce qu'il fête ses 40 ans
oui depuis
1981 le centre socioculturel alfred de
vigny s'est installé à voisins le
bretonneux et ce sont donc 40 bougies à
mettre sur le gâteau le vendredi 1er
juillet donc parmi nos deux invités
julien billot bonjour à vous tous genres
donc vous êtes la directrice du centre
alfred de vigny depuis dix jours c'est
très récent
vous vous êtes le président du centre al
fête des vignes depuis toulouse depuis
un mois maintenant 38 ans
[Rires]
à 38 à peu près donc vous êtes donc vous
avez vu naître avoué cet établissement
j'imagine que vous êtes heureux et fiers
de cet événement de ces cas je peux vous
dire que c'est attendu parce que on n'a
pas été gâté avec l'aco vide on devait
faire en 2000 en 2020 en 2020 et la
maintenance et 2022 bon ça y est ça on a
tout mis en place je crois que c'est un
très très bel événement oui je crois
qu'on a on a quand même une très très
belle maison et moi je l'appelle
toujours ma chapelle on a depuis que je
connais cette maison il ya une très
belle colonne vertébrale ce que je
choisis ainsi si cette colonne
vertébrale de cet édifice fonctionne
bien c'est quand même les membres du
bureau le conseil d'administration on à
la municipalité quand même qu'ils nous
aident énormément on a toutes les
instances que ça soit l'euskal que ce
soit la région que sur les départements
on a les sponsors on à les aider les
adhérents mais on a aussi où on a une
force énorme c'est les bénévoles je
crois que et c'est la joie de vivre et
là je crois que tout le monde est en
stress moi particulièrement que
j'attends avec impatience je pense de
mauvaise nuit mais je crois que ce sera
une très très belle retraite
alors justement donc le centre culturel
comme vous l'avez dit à peu près mille
quatre cent quarante cinq membres vont
démonter on a monté en 2010 avant la
crise on était à 2 pts à son comble et
ça a perdu un tiers et je pense quand
j'ai fait les sondages dans toute la
situation dite de france on retrouve
exactement la perte de ces gens les gens
se posent des questions ou sont toujours
regarder ce qui se passe actuellement on
a encore je voulais qu'on fasse une
rentrée septembre
complète comme les 8 19 maintenant on va
tendre à l'avenir va vous proposer en
tout cas diverses activités culturelles
linguistiques ou encore artistique et
donc ce vendredi 1er juillet vous
organisez donc des festivités les
grandes festivités est ce que jules yeux
bien vous pouvez un peu bien présentées
à l'offre il ya un programme assez
chargé alors déjà faut savoir que c'est
gratuit et que c'est ouvert à tout le
monde c'est pas réservé à aux adhérents
et
donc au cours de la soirée nous bloquons
tout une rue la rue qui est devant le
centre alfred de vigny pour les
festivités donc il y aura des spectacles
il y aura des concerts il y aura
énormément d'animation de 16h30 à 20h
pour les enfants gratuites gérés par des
animateurs qu'on a engagés aussi dans le
cadre de l'événement il y aura des
concerts jusqu'à 23h notamment foulbazar
bande ou un type qui font énormément de
reprise il y aura une démonstration de
country aura du look ukulélé aussi une
petit une petite demi heure c'est très
varié on a essayé d'impliquer aussi les
habitants et les diffé les voisins et
les adhérents du centre dans
l'organisation de cet événement comme on
le fait à chaque fois donc il ya
énormément de bénévoles qui se sont
impliqués notamment pour les moments
festifs comme l'apéro comme le défaire
il va y avoir beaucoup de choses qui
soutenons et pas mal de surprises aussi
pour pour rendre honneur aussi à tous
ces gens qui se sont investis depuis 40
ans dans le centre et il y aura de quoi
se nourrir puisqu'on il y a trois food
truck différents qui propose des crêpes
un des hamburgers et 1 cuisine du monde
comme ça tout le monde pourra rester
jusqu'à la fin de la soirée et pouvoir
manger bon et ceux qui habitent un petit
peu plus nos voisins je crois qu'il ya
un petit train alors oui alors le petit
par le petit train n'est pas une navette
le petit train sera un petit train pour
pour tous les habitants attractifs qui
fera un tour justement pour montrer
aussi les différentes institutions de la
commune voilà comme ça ça permet aussi
aux différentes personnes qui
viendraient pas forcément de
voisins-le-bretonneux de découvrir aussi
la commune sous un autre aspect un peu
plus attractif un programme très riche
du coup pour fêter ses 40 ans du centre
alfred de vigny félicitations pour
toutes ces animations
qui vous allez y je crois qu'il faut
remercier comme un ami municipalité tous
les services que ce soit logistique
comme etc qui nous aider énormément
et je pense que ils vont être sur le
terrain dès vendredi matin pour
l'installer tout tout personnel
municipal vont être à l'oeuvre et je
pense qu'il faut remercier madame le
maire pour mettre à notre disposition
ce service est alors un peu rappelé la
date c'est le 1er juillet vendredi qui
arrive voilà ça sert 30 à 23 heures
merci à vous deux d'abord été avec nous
alors je profite de cette fenêtre
culturel pour vous parler de cette
sortie vocaux édition numéro 5 g pas
l'exemplaire avec moi va pouvoir me
l'apporté s'il vous plaît nicolas qui
étaient en coulisses c'est derrière
merci beaucoup nicolas m'apporte
l'exemplaire de vocaux donc c'est un
magazine pour précisions qui sort une
fois par an qui est indépendant et
gratuit son credo c'est de mettre en
avant l'effervescence et la créativité
culturelle et du territoire de seine
aval alors on retrouve dans cette
édition dans ce magazine d actualité
notamment au tour cette année 2022 de la
réouverture de la maison zola et du
musée dreyfus à hamedan mais aussi des
rencontres 1 par exemple une rencontre
que il y a ceux sur sur cette édition
une rencontre qui est proposé de
isabelle outrebon isabelle outre bon
voilà je vous montre mieux cette une qui
qui tient un tir lieu écologique instar
hardricourt ce tiers lieux écologique
s'appelle la fabrique nature alors
vocaux et distribué dans 300 points de
diffusion dans le nord des yvelines
entre sartrouville et mantes la jolie où
on retrouve ses éditions du magazine
vocaux dans les mairies les offices de
tourisme ont également les lieux
culturels et on écoute tout de suite le
fondateur du magazine
beaucoup c'est un magazine culturel
gratuit qui met en valeur le territoire
de la seine aval le nord des yvelines
dans différents domaines de la culture
que ce soit du patrimoine de la danse de
leurs plastiques de la musique
le magazine est né il ya cinq ans
maintenant on est au cinquième numéro
par un groupe d'amis en fait des
passionnés de patrimoine de culture on
s'est rendu compte que sur le territoire
finalement on n'avait pas beaucoup de
support de qualité pour valoriser les
lieux culturels donc on s'est dit qu'on
allait faire
[Musique]
par exemple de la réouverture du musée
emile zola 1 mais dans une rubrique
aussi sur un artiste donc un portfolio
aurélie richard on a une rubrique
musique une rubrique gastronomie ne
rubrique aussi sur la graineterie à
houilles un lieu d'expression artistique
donc on retrouve voilà les mêmes
rubriques d'un numéro à l'autre
le domaine royal de marly à la fois le
parc et le musée en lui-même également
qu' qui est à découvrir
[Musique]
on l'attendait avec impatience on en a
parlé en début d'émission mathilde on va
terminer sur sur les manèges vous avez
les manèges alors j'aime beaucoup les
manèges sauf ceux où il ya un peu de
vertige j'avoue c'est pas trop ma tasse
de thé mais ça tombe bien puisque la
fête des loges on va en parler il ya
deux des manèges pour tous les goûts et
donc ça elle revit la fête des loges
revient à saint germain aller jusqu'au
15 août célia vous il avait passé
l'après-midi d'ailleurs avec le che
visse gmt et michael et demi d'euros
vous vous êtes lancé un défi avec
michael alors on va voir qui est le plus
courageux c'est un sujet de ces lianes
400 go michael et demi d'euros et
bixente mayence antiste evans
[Musique]
aujourd'hui vous pouvez le voir nous
sommes à la fête dès l'âge 360 neuvième
édition cette année 150 attractions et
des dizaines de restaurants ici sur ce
site alors michael je propose qu'on ce
défi un défi oui et je te propose comme
premier défi le train fantôme j'adore ça
je connais si on va voir si c'est le cas
alors voix de mon côté je te défie sur
l'une des nouvelles attractions du 6 et
le bateau un pirate il est orange et il
va
[Musique]
et ça y est le train fantôme
lasse pas
d'accord
allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça va boileau
je suis pas du tout rassuré
tous
shocking voilà ceux ci dément célia
je t'aime pas du tout
[Musique]
allez
[Applaudissements]
à sa demande après jour tout doucement
moi ça va mieux comme ça en fait tu vas
perdre le niveau 1 ont le niveau qu'eux
[Musique]
bon bah c'est terminé tu as michael
c'était simple finalement
bravo mais quel beau ces liens a partout
partout pas le tenter de compostelle est
supérieur supérieur on va faire une des
plus grosses attractions
bah oui on y va ayant surfé l'extrême
extrême ou la wii
[Musique]
pas michael bay ou
malige
[Musique]
paris
c'est pas si simple que ça on est petit
canard
n'en rater encore
et voilà
j'ai défilé
célia enfin une activité qui va nous
rassembler ici assange armand les
chemises on va bien se régaler ici à
milo on est dans un des restaurants
incontournable de la scène dès l'âge
alors bon venu beaucoup de choses
beaucoup de belles choses beaucoup de
bonnes choses notamment du jarret avec
des frites ça a l'air très appétissants
toi ces liens tu as mangé un petit mix
des yeux durant ses choix que tu vas
faire chauffer sur cette pierre est
notre cameraman le gourmand juste
derrière la caméra ranger le port se
laissait vraiment incontournable ici
exactement
sillage il faut manger ce et cce
sérpahin ses murs exactement et c'est à
découvrir ici à la fête des loges
assange en vendée jusqu'au 15 août
bravo c'est bon
on peut dire que vous avez gagné haut la
main ce défi face à mu tél alors vous
aviez déjà gagné un défi face à justine
je me souviens en escalade là c'est la
scène mickey championne des dépenses et
bien
des meilleurs vins cuba mon secret où je
pète secret ans et le talent voilà
ça pas trop pas trop le vertige derrière
la caméra les suivre j'aime quand même
faire une petite pause après le repas
parce qu' il fallait digérer quand
est-ce que c'était bien ce que vous avez
mangé c'était très très bons mots et
puis comme on dit dans le reportage on
s'est vraiment les choses à manger bas à
la fédé là je veux vraiment les
incontournables donc non non c'était
c'était très sympa et c'est sympa c'est
de revoir les images une attraction
préférée j'étais moi j'ai bien aimé être
derrière mickaël dans le train fantôme
puisque ces réactions c'était vraiment
exceptionnel et célia fait toute seule
l'extrême j'ai fait tout ce talent
l'extrême il a trés c'était très bien
non franchement j'aurais vraiment à l
extrême c'était bien après mange on y en
avait d'autres aussi qu'on n'a pas cité
moi j'aime beaucoup aussi le top spin
c'est ils font 4,5 looping aussi c'est
effrayant mais c'est sympa il y en a eu
et qu'on n'a pas tenté c'est une toute
nouvelle aussi c'est un élan autour de
80 mètres de haut ou iliad monte petit à
petit il ya la descente d'un coup
week-end je ne sais pas combien mettrait
pas plus
annoncé puis cette sensation d'un sessad
de oba aussi c'est
compliqué à gérer une voix du coeur et
on a pris un extrait et je pense qu on
la mettra sur les réseaux à
prochainement puisque ça va ça vaut le
détour en france eh bien merci en tout
cas à vous d'avoir été avec nous un
plateau s'est déjà j'ai juste une
dernière question avant de terminer au
fond peu comment faire avec des enfants
parce que là c'était des attractions
quand même qui faisait plutôt peur on
avait l'impression d'un michael faisait
la pêche aux canards
l'un des stands ya vraiment de tout pour
tous les enfants et même pour tous peut
utiliser trois ans il ya certaines
attractions qui sont accessibles ckoi
150 attraction 850 donc mais avec un
choix c'est pour tous les âges pour tous
les âges et bien je vous remercie encore
venu avec nous un plateau pour en parler
c'est du coup la fin de cette émission
grèce et la fin de cette émission le 7 8
qui est bien sûr à retrouver en replay
sur notre site internet tv 78 sur notre
application mobile on aura également
peut-être des extraits à vous proposer
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est un plaisir
d'être avec vous matière une première
même si on a dépassé un petit peu le
temps qui est de l'ong thématique est en
tout cas c'était un plaisir de parler de
toutes ces thématiques on rappelle un et
de l'emploi on a parlé également de
découverte et aussi de choses beaucoup
plus légères sport culture avec si cette
fête des loges les 40 aussi du centre
alfred de vigny merci nous avoir suivi
sur tv 78 et à très vite
[Musique]